We put it on your daughter application. Larry. Oh they wasn't as a practicing addict. In this area there wasn't.
There wasn't the volunteers there wasn't the prawn wasn't the prostitution there wasn't all asshole marks.
Of addiction that. My. My friends in the city. When through. I was a lot gentler like. In many ways like. We still.
You know i think we were still a lot more physically active i mean we still climbed up and down mountains and hills
and cost of war her and. We still seem to use a lot more. Yeah addiction has a lock on that.
To me out here than it would have been in the cities for sure. Laid away without a doubt closer.
Question mark wright is a rock. I guess son his son and sid you know.
Life is a lot kind of frederick's in the country all the country addicts that i know and.
In my own experience applies in this is well. We just didn't have to do what pearl city attics. To do and then.
I never had to cross shoot myself you know i didn't have to steal from people other than just you know.
Charging to six open and mounts of money for you know i didn't have to. You know sell my soul to be an addict here and.
You know like god. If i couldn't get it together to cook a meal i could always find the right.
Go and have a meal there i mean i think that kept me alive it kept me out of trouble for a really long time.
You know the id time i ever did go shoot a city and.
You know i was a practicing addict i mean it was just terrific i had a really hard time for about three
or four months until i could get it together to come home again and. I think. I mean from a lot.
Up front about my diction of course everybody knew. But i didn't go around discussing it with paypal and i guess.
I didn't pick up. Heroin. I had about three years of.
I think when i first came the country and when it wasn't here for a while and.
You know i sort of did things in town i was part of the community
and said people gave me a lot of leeway for a long time after i'd sort of because i'm a practicing heroin addict again.
I think people still loved me and. You know i could get away with saying just this. You know junkie in town and.
I mean that had a lot to do with the progression of my disease to you know like. You start off as this sort of.
Guy young thing. And it takes a long time to the disease of addiction to way down and.
You know about the tunnels thirty two. I was a pretty you know i was a pretty want to.
Junkie and i don't want a lot of my friendships and a lot of my family by that time and.
I guess the only thing i've gone for it was that i was a country junkie
and that i could survive a lot more easily here. In terms of. I guess muff my physical self and masaki than i could.
As city junkie as well i was always one of those sort of junkies that. Kept a lot of fronts up.
So i was my son was always very well dressed and.
You know there was always money for shoes and food and so on and i kept it from him.
That was a junkyard very protected humorous a lot of people don't do that so much. I certainly didn't.
And i mean my mothering front was great because i could side of myself i'm not too bad a junkie because my kids.
Does that mean the other.
And so that was another part of my i don't know about the process of my diction bicycling in the.
You know he grew up around smoking.
But everybody's kids do you know the cops come to our house one day the bastards
and max out on a bad diet like a pillow and that was his you know.
Big climb to find the you know the cops kind of not set on the dark night in finding. And.
I mean most people's kids are probably in that position in that. We all had to tell our children that.
You know what we smoke is a label and so if anybody ever asks you about it at school
or whatever we do not do that thing and and. That was just reality so.
It was always brought up within the framework of that. Illegality i suppose and. I'm it's not colleagues.
Was uncool in the early dies but so is alcohol so i mean we never went and sat in pubs
or anything like that like if you're a good he'd be distant going to pubs in and out of going to pubs for about ten
or twelve years it wasn't until we had the media ease that i even ventured into the newman pub
and that was i just said that i started drinking. And also the kids that inboard up and.
Within the framework of an extended family situation here i mean that's one of the. Things not. I mean.
In country areas you have that but in communal. Societies like like. We live in here on main that. That.
That's even more fundamental and then the kids get together and i hang around in groups and then we look after them.
And i mean as a community really believe me. You know the kids and all the parents and all the kids and.
All the kids want to get together and you're looking after these groups and so.
And basically in that situation i mean people kerry i mean people.
You know if people are having hard times whether it's through realizing ships' economics addiction whatever.
I mean people get in there and say what's happening and help each other out and.
I think that probably the kids suffered a lot less than.
I would have a has in commission flat in the city
or something on that as well i mean that's the thing about country addiction to i mean it is different to the city
addiction or the city process of addiction and not magic not there are people with good with kids
and so on who are city addicts but. I mean it's. It's a very different scenario where we all have lived and.
We all had kids and kids went to school together in a dive to each other and.
And we looked after each other's kids as well
and so you know it was it was a really different trip to an os lighted site if you're living in a flat
and some killed or somewhere in the dark. Other mothers like. We all knew everybody like we did.
And we'd go to the school you know like we would put on dark glasses
and go to the school fight because we were still part of the community. You know it's interesting you know. Yeah. Yeah.
I think it's very very hard in that paper kind of rifle. I think is very hard. In terms of.
Community notions of addiction because people kind of arrive by addicts. And say them as the monstrous other.
And i say them as. Somebody to be really feeling people forget that.
Everybody has an addict or an alcoholic in their families and i put the two into the category.
I had an uncle who is an alcoholic. Somebody else has a sister who was an alcoholic.
Somebody has a husband who's a drug addict you know and. It's really important to not let humans. Humanness. Flour why.
Flow out the dry and. I think that when people talk about the. Addicts. And the drug problem.
I just forget it's a person who lives in the house next door
and it's really really important to have that sort of notion of compassion
and humanness with with talking about the problem because otherwise you can't get any any community kind of.
Cohesiveness happening. If you split the community you don't.
You don't have to in fact search for the solution you can just shove.
Shove the people out of the community you can shut you know close down the methadone program. Shut down and they look.
And then you have people starting to die. And then you have people starting to get desperate.
And again you have you know. Possibly a serious problem happening held sway but you know.
Probably a serious problem still happening here i mean there are kind of concrete.
Solvable solution is happening this is just the idea i think that we have to look at the problem as a community.
And and try and sort of. Say the people with problems.
As our friends you know and i mean that's really hard for people who don't personally know.
The addicts like you just walk past people outside the right by side. And say some. You know person it's really hard.
It's really easy to sort of unify the nation and and. Things get hot dark to you know people sit around in groups.
Talking about. The problem.
And i just say you know something's got to be done about it something's got to be done about it.
But i mean that by simply just prompt some kind of vigilante action rather than a part of a positive solution.
Don't go. So.
Well i think one thing i think part of the reason it's visible is because i think women's drug problem is necessarily
worse than that a lot about apply science probably better than i want to i we've got friends who have moved here from
darlinghurst.
They can't believe the furore about the drug problem because i think this is heaven compared to what i know.
Darlinghurst. I think the drug. You know. The problems with addiction.
Everywhere i think one of the things about nim than i'm one of the healthy things about naman is that it's not.
It's not kept behind closed doors and swept under the carpet. It's basically. Pretty much up front.
And it's pretty pretty discussed on a community level and it's a nice try. And a lot of people try to address it.
On this level. And there's a lot of played within the community trying to do something positive a bad. And so.
Yeah it probably seems a lot worse than it is like i said before the drug problem in nimbin is because basically just a
libel. Over simplified lives for a lot of other problems online. For homelessness for ten i'd run allies.
For alcoholism. For poverty. Through all these sorts of things online people.
I mean all those problems come under the live on the drug problem in most people's minds. Who are observing it.
And we're small country ten. There's one straight. It's very visible. It's very visible and. What is visible is just.
Young people sitting around outside the bible and whether
or not they in fact have a drug problem isn't the point on the nine i will just the people who are drinking.
For a while i mean most people go through problem. Drug and alcohol use.
You know between the age of eighteen and twenty two than i do kids which is doing that. Really normal thing again.
Doing it visibly. You know i don't i might just as easily just be you know.
Fifteen year olds who don't want to go to school just sitting around trying to scare people.
You know just looking groovy. Having fun and there's also this interest so i think that it's in it's in their.
I think the certain vested interests that it's in there. To their advantage. To to clean up the tale.
So that their businesses or properties
or whatever that they're trying to sell to sort of reasonably affluent middle class people with.
Because they will then where is his cell phone call us festival going. And i want to sell lend or war.
War services or goods to them. I want the ten claim that because i think these people scare them.
Will scare these people away and. So i think that there's this people whose.
Illusions like arc of lucian's about the myth of nimon of being shattered by the reality.
They've got to visit best interest in their allusions i want to find somebody to blame
or they drain didn't come true and. I mean all these people got various vested interests in in beating up this.
Heart about the drug problem in inman and really like. I don't think it's any worse than anywhere else.
I think it's probably a lot healthier than other places because. Because a lot of us see it on a lot of.
Because it is that it is up front. And i know it is being talked about and table trying to find solutions in its name.
And i was thinking then you know. I see you particularly. Person who was really offended when he was asked if you want.
By moving down the street and save these people to be sort of really kind of feast and drug addicts and.
I see no difference between kids using. Or getting a bit pissed.
And the why we all sat around twenty years ago getting really quite feisty and smoking. I mean.
Is that acceptable is it acceptable to sort of sit in this mine straight. Really started and. And quite kind.
On smoking. But not on other drugs like i think one of the hardest things about newman is that.
This is drug specificity that it's ok to smoke. Smoking dope steal. And to me. That is held us back as a community.
It's held a spec in terms of what people achieve in the community. I mean it's very much process and work i think but.
You know like if you're sitting around smoking. You don't do as much.
You don't have the most wonderful guns in the world maybe you don't. Sort of be as creative or whatever but.
To make a drug is a drug is a drug and. There's just as many problems with people sitting around smoking.
As there are you know. With drunks. Bating up on paypal. Always. You know people sticking needles in there saying.
I mean this is this is sort of acceptability about drugs that. You know it's. It's ok to sit on straight.
Or to sit somewhere. Smoking dope and it's not ok to use the other drugs and off on that really fancy.
The bottom line is always people got their own barrier to push in the play ball.
And the people who get vilified in the most power. Palace playboy in the community by sadly. The young.
Harmless kids the addicks. The sock patients have been kicked out of the their half why. Has is these are the people.
These the table that.
Always problems everywhere has got their blind for some reason and then plain old man it makes it all very simple
and easy if we can just blind everything on these sort of outlandish. Added looking scruffy paypal.
Wondering just get rid of them then everything will be i can and.
And the people sitting around getting drunk in the pub think you know.
It's all a problem and if we go out and beat up a couple of them
and teach them a lesson you know everything will be ok and. You know it's just. Silo wise just silo. Wide off the mark.
Yet this simplistic. Simplistic sort of vigilante sort of.
The loss of his his push to the wife of solving always problems all.
Always someone it's funny because in many many ways newman was about being marginal on the end.
Twenty years ago we were all very marginalized by our attitudes and ideologies at the time.
And you know as i said before fashions china. And. And i guess we grow older and and.
The marginal become more offensive to see many well yes. You know i still do i get. I don't like.
Charges because i smell. You know like i reckon people can always have a birdbath or whatever but.
You know that sort of thing of. Of the. The module do become the status quo. Yeah. And we have become the status quo.
And stuff like that. When i was using drugs. I used to work in the rainforest because our grass.
Got they to grow dark and. Look at things like huge strength of ons.
That were quite extraordinary and i got got i'm so lucky to live here and look at this sort of thing.
And i could recognise that intellectually
but i only realised after i got clean from all drugs that in fact i had no connection with that reality and.
Probably the best part about living here from a particular living he totally drug free is to look at my environment
and to be part of my own bond. And in some kind of connection with it on a spiritual level and. Just feel a real.
Numinous joy in that. And i don't. Experience that. In other places. As much as i do here.
I mean i can walk in parts of sydney and feel that in parts of melbourne i mean it's not a peculiarly.
Country experienced by any by any stretch but i. You feel. And here we go into the realms of the arcane.
I do feel that newman is. Is a very special spot. Not for the people.
Not for anything that we've done in the last two hundred years here. But i'd. I do feel it as.
As one of those places that. Use very magical moments siani would you can describe it some.
Sometimes hear your heart leaps out. In a really beautiful why and. I always get homesick for this area.
And want and want to come home and. I suppose you know any place can become home.
But for me this pain this place has become a very special spot.
And i guess the people to you know like the people who star eight. Are a lot of fun.
You know and people have come and gone i've the years and i mean night. You know have the applies here.
But for the people who came here. And decided to stay and have just kept on year after year. I mean we are a community.
And that. That sense of communities. Is very special also because.
Certainly i mean i've lived in other country towns you can walk down the street.
And you cannot inside hello to everybody but. I mean we share a continuity and can continue in here.
But that goes back over a long time and. And that's a special thing to. Largest think that the really.
The really strong thing about the community up here is the fact that we do. Really sort of.
Cherish a dog versity a papal warming here. The junkie's came come morning behind the kids come. The ferals come.
The saw our patients come. Give me a. And i you know. Well the thing here.
Basically all these people come and and they tell you can they tighten is they i mean.
They're not vilified for that they're. If on me.
If i want to get on in the community they're excepted the doors i've been on in life
and get on the dog versity here is that the humans is pretty much cherished
and i think i think that's a fantastic thing. I think that's the issue that's going on at the moment i mean.
The pressures in it so it's a saudi i mean.
They want to marginalize people like that that's the global sort of pressure. Marginalize everything.
I mean what you've got here is. Is incredible. An incredible range of. Just all sorts and nine year olds and and.
And just all sorts of people and we get on and on then we do get on and.
And the community as a whole does really resist this. Pressure to marginalize and this is pressure to.
To vilify are not gentle paypal and. I think that's the strength of this community and that's and that's.
That's what a lot of play i mean a lot of the al sit was who have been here a long time. Online.
That's where our strength law is in. You know a desire to to preserve the diversity not any of the rainforests.
But that of. The fumin culture and people and all that the different subcultures that exist and.
And i think that's one in all go on and that's why she's like a drug addiction. Will be sort of kicked a bad out.
And keep the bad. You know in the out and that's why.
That's why when when when when commercial and economic pressures come on. On to this community. To clean itself up and.
You know i rub out the messy bits and to move them on. Online. The community will push back. Because.
I think that diversity is. Is where our strength flaw is and i think. I think you know my entire. You know against.
Against the laid all. The commercial.
You know the cultural pressures of we're bombarded with and i think that's the strength. Community and one reason our.